do you think it's possible to
heal the aspects of yourself that are
triggered and then project on to other
people or are unhealthy perhaps an
unhealthy relationship and
an action that you take as a coping
mechanism is it possible to actually get
to all those things without
unpacking
your childhood and understanding your
relational
uh
how you relate to your mom your dad your
caretakers um
traumatic events throughout your life
and i'm not talking about getting your
arm cut off but i feel like we're all
getting a little better at understanding
trauma it's just a really emotional
thing that happened to you and it
doesn't have to be big on the outside it
just feels big on the inside do you
think we can get to that without getting
to the family and getting to the roots
and the childhood and inner child stuff
i i don't think so i and
i i wish i could say yes here's a
shortcut you know
here's the super secret shortcut that
heals trauma without actually having to
like dig into your past i mean
ultimately it's it's
you know the way the human brain works
is it's it's a
it's a trigger and response mechanism
right it's like it's a pattern builder
and
the earlier the earlier you go into your
life the more fundamental those patterns
are um
the more they underlie everything else
that has come since and so that's why
that it's like if you have dysfunction
somewhere in your life
um and it could be anything it could be
you know struggling with anxiety it
could be relationship problems it could
be
impostor syndrome or self-sabotage or
you know substance addiction all these
things like it's there's some
ultimately what that dysfunction is is
is a pattern in your brain that's that's
not healthy it's not working
and uh and you need to go break that and
and
kind of realign it
and um
and generally speaking it's
you know the bigger the dysfunction the
further down
the stack of patterns you have to dig to
um and it's like
it's funny the whole like digging into
the childhood thing and and
you know figuring you know mom didn't
hug me enough or dad said this or that
like sometimes i do think it gets
overrated i think sometimes people do
focus on it a little bit too much like
here's the funny thing about it is that
if you if you
start kind of wallowing in in your past
and your childhood and stuff that can
actually become a new form of avoidance
for dealing with the present
um there's a lot of people who
spend so much time digging through their
baggage in the past that
it's like become kind of a convenient
excuse for not dealing with whatever
problem there they have in the present
so in that sense
i think it could be overrated at times
but
at the same time it's like
it's better to spend too much time back
there than
not enough you know
ultimately
understanding yourself who you are why
you are the way you are um is such just
an important piece of knowledge for
everything you do in life
and you really can't figure that out
until you you go back and spend time
with that spend time with like how your
your family environment was what your
neighborhood was like you know the
shitty things that happened to you as a
kid
all those things matter and you know
maybe some matter
a little bit more than others or some
maybe some don't matter as much as you
thought they did or they actually matter
a lot more than you thought they did
but ultimately it's like the value is
actually just
developing that knowledge base
of yourself becoming kind of an expert
on your own patterns and your own
uh scripts and narratives that you have
yeah i'm kind of fascinated with the
question of whether or not
we can ever truly experience someone
else objectively
or not
as in we have our own lens that we see
everything through and is it possible to
actually see someone like totally
objectively
i don't think so
which is crazy to think i mean that
should really like hit for people that
should hit that you know
i mean
you can't see someone objectively you're
seeing it through your own
the things you think like i don't know
like a stupid example and things i
always have the silliest examples for
when i learn these things because they
they they happen in the simplest of ways
but it's like somebody a friend could be
like oh my forehead's really big and i'm
like oh my god i don't even see that
like you're beautiful and that's because
i don't it's not my it's not something i
think about right so like
i'm not seeing it because it's not in me
it's not something i think about right
so um where on the other hand you know i
might see someone that's
um you know really short and since i'm
five one i'd be like oh yeah
yeah that's not an example i've thought
about but it's something that would
register for me what is what are the
keys then that other people hold for us
as um
in life like how do we use them
because
we can't we also can't see ourselves
right i mean would you do you agree i
feel like that like i need other people
to see me i i think it's one of those
things where like you can be more
objective or less objective but you're
never going to be entirely objective you
know like it's it's you can get better
at it but you're never nobody's ever
going to nail it
you know it's it's ultimately
you know human perception didn't evolve
for accuracy it evolved for survival and
so the reason we have a lot of the
biases that we have the misp like the
delusions that we have the way we we
uh you know it's it's one day you look
at a person and they seem really
uh really cool and attractive and the
next day they seemed like a horrible
person even though nothing really
changed like like all these little
things were kind of built into our brain
because
ultimately they had like adaptive
purposes
uh for survival for evolutionary
survival and
i think once you understand that and
understand that like okay
just because you think something's true
or or believes something is true like
doesn't necessarily make it true it kind
of frees you to start
um questioning a lot of these things and
and trying to
trying to make that effort to be a
little bit more objective or
to get a little bit closer to the truth
and i think that absolutely applies to
ourselves i mean i think everybody has
had an experience at some point where
either their perception of themselves
was completely off base
or you've had a friend before who like
can't whose perception of themselves is
completely off base and like you're just
like wow how do they not see
the reality in front of them right like
how how warped must their perceptions be
to actually think this is true about
themselves when like me and all the
people around them can see it's not true
like i think we've all had that
experience before we've seen it in other
people and
and
it it happens in ourselves as well and
so it's kind of like
we've all got little blind spots and um
and so we have to be like
i think it's an important
process of questioning
uh where are my blind spots or like
where am i
uh
where am i not being objective and how
can i how can i be better and it's a
never-ending process because it's just
our hardware is not built to be
objective it's
it's built to be subjective why is it
why is it that it takes
sort of the mirroring aspect of nature
of being a human to
to see i don't why why do we need
someone else to see ourselves
if you look at humans as as just an
animal
we actually we we suck at most things
like if you compare us to the other apes
like we're super weak we're really slow
we can't climb we're [ __ ] yeah we
sunburn like crazy like we don't have
sonar we can't see at night
can't swim more [ __ ] like it's
it's
if you were to like put us on paper next
to like all
most of the other like eight great apes
and and a lot of other mammals and stuff
like we're bad at we're very mediocre at
most things like the human superpower
the reason why we are
so dominant on the planet
is we developed language and social
relationships and the ability to
cooperate and so there's like a very
fundamental like arguably the most
fundamental
piece of our psychology is that we find
meaning in relationships and
um
and so we're just very
primally driven
to
uh want and experience intimacy and
love and camaraderie and and have a
supportive network around us like it's
it's if you look at all the data on
well-being and
happiness and longevity it's like
it's relationships are always first and
then everything else is like distant
second third fourth and um
and so i think it's just
it's a it's like the most fundamental
component of our
uh psychological well-being and
a huge part of that is
we're constantly
negotiating
our sense of identity in our sense of
self like we're never quite sure who we
are you know it's like you know okay
well i've written some books but like am
i really an author or did i just get
lucky a couple of times you know or like
does that mean i have to write books
again or does that mean that's the only
thing i am or maybe i want to be
something else you know so there's this
constant like discovery process that's
happening within ourselves we like and
need for other people around us to to
kind of validate those discoveries or to
challenge those discoveries to kind of
push back on them or or
perhaps even discover things about us
for us you know things that we can't see
in ourselves they see in us and this is
this is what intimacy is this is what
you know it's when you feel seen when
you feel like oh my god this person gets
me they know who i am like that's that
feeling of comfort and security and
intimacy is like that's
it's it's when your discovery of
yourself matches somebody else's
perception of you and um wait say that
again say that again nice and slow
so i mean this is what intimacy is when
your discovery of yourself or your
perception of yourself is matched by
somebody who sees you the same way and
it's an incredibly profound and
emotional experience for all of us and
it's what what binds us together you
know all these crazy emotions that we
all struggle to deal with like
ultimately that a lot of their purpose
is to make us all
attached to one another feel attached to
one another and want to sacrifice and
help one another and
that's what makes our species so
successful but then i have to ask
why are relationships so hard this is
not an uncommon question for you i would
watch every single interview you've ever
done
and every single day that you've
struggled you're like why is this so
hard i at least ask that to myself every
single day why are relationships so hard
um and these can be you know the
romantic ones are probably kind of what
i'm most curious about but this applies
to
family and children as well like the
closest one closest people to us it's
you know in our human nature to be in
community and and have love and
relationships yet it's the thing that we
almost have the most resistance around
yeah and i think it's for the exact same
reason because you know the the more
exposed your identity is to
ten times as much
um
and especially if you
come from a background a family history
where people are not
you know
it's not healthy like there's not a
healthy intimacy in your family
environment when you're young
you develop all sorts of patterns and
triggers around intimacy that
that cause more pain
and so this is why it's like you know
maybe you go to work and your co-worker
kind of makes a joke of like oh you're
so messy you should clean your desk and
you're like ha ha you know screw you but
then you go home
and your partner comes home and is like
wow you're so messy you should clean up
your mess and you just [ __ ] explode
like it's just because it it's they have
deeper access
to you in terms of
um how you see yourself you know your
co-worker is just a co-worker it's like
who cares what he thinks um
but when it's your partner and they've
seen all of you and they know all of you
and they have access to all of you at
all times and then they say something
that and especially if that something
has a long history of causing you pain
in your life
it can just set you off
[Music]